le genre d'affaires qu'on lit plutôt
dans la presse corse mais cette fois
c'est bien un garagiste de château
renault qui a été victime de racket deux
ans de menacer un préjudice total de 70
mille euros les deux malfaiteurs
finalement arrêté ils sont jugés en ce
moment même au tribunal de tours romain
delville bonsoir vous suivez la faire
pour nous un procès de la violence et de
la lâcheté
et pendant plus de deux ans c'est un
véritable calvaire un cas vécu alban et
marin propriétaire du château du garage
citroën de chateaurenaud l'histoire en
fait de tragique sous emprise une
histoire tragique de raquette souvent
prises avec des menaces de mort sur sa
famille des menaces de mort sur ses
enfants des menaces aussi de brûler son
garage citroën au début c'est à dire à
l'automne 2010 9 le prévenu réclame
d'avoir des réparations automobiles
gratuites fait esclandre dans le garage
de chateaurenaud alban emma parle alors
d'un engrenage qui commence et c'est un
engrenage qui va aller très loin tout
d'abord en numéraire vous le disais plus
de 71 1000 euros et puis des achats de
grosse cylindrée au profit du prévenu
une mercedes une bmw une porsche
panamera un dodge un porsche cayenne une
ford mustang un camion ou encore une
caravane art il ya aussi des téléphones
portables une télé un frigo est plein
d'autres objets hors de son côté le
prévenu issus de la communauté des gens
du voyage de chateaurenaud moïse guen se
présente comme quelqu'un de très
religieux dans le box il est surtout
déranger sa logique en fait et très
personnelle par exemple quand ils volent
des objets au garage puis ils réclament
ensuite de se faire payer en fait parler
par le propriétaire du garage de même il
soutient lors d'une écoute téléphonique
qu'en fait c'est la victime qui lui doit
15000 euros et puis un jour tout s'est
arrêté c'était le 19 octobre dernier
c'est le jour où elle banc et marc avec
son épouse sont allés porter plainte à
la gendarmerie
le préjudice total est évalué à plus de
170 mille euros moïse guen risquent
jusqu'à dix ans de prison